[Applaudissements]
mes
amis la politique ce sont aussi ces
moments ces moments où on est juste
heureux de se retrouver et nous n'allons
pas bouder notre plaisir parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes heureux
d'être ensemble ils avaient dit que nous
serions
divisés ils avaient dit que la justice
nous empêcherait de nous appeler les
républicains ils avaient dit que nous
n'aurions pas le droit d'avancer et vous
êtes aujourd'hui la plus belle des
parce que vous êtes là parce que vous
êtes venus parce que vous êtes plus de
20000 autour de notre président et parce
que vous vous n'avez pas renoncé vous
êtes admirabl militant des
républicains et vous êtes venus pour
prouver à ceux qui disaient que nous
étions morts que nous sommes plus
vivants que jamais vous êtes venus pour
prouver tout simplement cette évidence
aujourd'hui la droite est de retour et
elle est enfin à nouveau fière de ses
valeurs mais je ne voudrais
pas je ne voudrais pas que nous
oublions le chemin que nous avons
parcouru ensemble souvenez-vous il y a à
peine 6 mois l'état dans lequel nous
étions nous étions divisés nous étions
inaudibles nous ne portions plus la voix
de l'opposition et aujourd'hui nous
sommes à nouveau l'incarnation de
l'espoir des Français je le dis tout
ceci n'aurait pas été possible sans
l'énergie de Nicolas Sarkozi et je
voudrais que par vos applaudissements
vous remerciez celui qui a reconstruit
notre famille
politique aujourd'hui c'est l'heure du
renouveau c'est l'heure de la
refondation et pour chacun d'entre nous
cela doit être le retour à
l'essentiel une famille politique qui
assume et qui défend ses
valeurs mais personne ne doit oublier ce
qui nous a tué les
amis personne ne doit oublier ce qui a
failli nous
asphyxier les
divisions il peut y avoir de l'ambition
mais personne ne peut oublier qu'il n'y
aura aucune réussite individuelle qui ne
repose pas d'abord sur l'esprit d'équipe
et je vais le dire très clairement je ne
veux pas entendre parler maintenant des
primaires parce que les querelles ça
suffit et que notre seul travail c'est
de nous opposer il y a un seul mot
d'ordre l'unité l'unité l'unité
[Applaudissements]
oui oui vous en avez
assez vous en avez assez d'assister en
silence à tout le mal fait la majorité
socialiste à notre pays vous en avez
assez bien sûr on se dit l'opposition va
mieux si vous saviez comme je trouve
qu'elle n'est pas encore assez offensive
qu'elle n'est pas encore assez
déterminée est-ce que vous attendez
c'est une opposition qui soit encore
plus forte parce que la reconstruction
de notre famille ça n'est pas juste
changé de nom de plus en plus de
Français en ont assez qu'une minorité
confisque le débat public on naurait pas
le droit de parler
d'assistana on n'aurait pas le droit de
dire que Schengen ne fonctionne pas on
naurait pas le droit de poser la
question de l'immigration et bien moi je
revendique au nom des républicains le
droit de poser ces questions le droit
que ce soyons nous qui secouillons la
poussière dans un pays qui a besoin de
trouver une nouvelle valité et je
revendique pour vous le droit d'une
expression libre pour la
[Applaudissements]
droite alors
il paraît que les socialistes ne veulent
pas que nous nous appelions
républicains tant mieux tant
mieux mais pourquoi est-ce que cela les
gêne parce que eux ils ont trahi les
valeurs de la République et j'accuse les
socialistes d'avoir trahi les valeurs de
la République Christiane tobira quand
elle construit une justice quand elle
construit une justice qui s'occupe plus
délinquant que des victimes n'est pas la
justice de la République la justice de
la République c'est la fermeté et la
place d'un délinquant c'est en
prison j'accuse njette valau Belkassem
d'abétir la République
oui oui vous avez raison de réagir parce
que quand on supprime les bourses au
mérit quand on tire vers le bas nos
élèves quand on détruit le collège nous
ne sommes pas dans ce qui est l'école de
la République
celle à laquelle nous nous croyons c'est
l'école du mérite c'est l'école de
l'effort et che nous l'excellence n'est
pas un gros
mot
j'accuse j'accuse manuel
Vals d'asphyier la
République quand il étouffe les classes
moyennes quand il étouffe ceux qui
travaillent ceux qui ont travaillé
pendant toute leur vie et qui en onent
assz sous les socialistes de devoir
payer toujours plus et de devoir
recevoir toujours moins pour nous la
République c'est d'abord la défense des
classes moyennes et de ceux qui
respectent les règles du contrat
républicain et j'accuse
enfin j'accuse enfin François Hollande
d'avoir laissé s'éteindre la voix de la
France quand il ne porte plus le
leadership en Europe et qu'il laisse
sans réagir les chrétiens d'Orient se
faire massacrer
ça n'est pas là la voix de la France que
Nicolas Sarkozi lui avait supporté avec
fierté quand il était président de la
République mais s'opposer ne suffira pas
cela fait 30 ans que nous assistons au
recul des valeurs de la République nous
y avons parfois nous-mêm contribué il
faut avoir le courage de le reconnaître
et bien à partir d'aujourd'hui nous
devons réaffirmer nos valeurs oui être
républicain c'est croire au travail et
pas à laassistana et c'est exigé en
contrepartie du RSA 5 he de travail
d'intérêt général comme nous aurions dû
le faire
oui être
républicain c'est croire aux valeurs de
la famille et dans notre famille
politique la GPA et la PMA ne pourront
jamais faire partie des valeurs que nous
défendons nous nous sommes attachés à la
famille
[Applaudissements]
oui être républicain c'est croire aux
entrepreneurs c'est reconnaître que le
principe de précaution a été une lourde
erreur c'est reconnaître qu'il faut
remettre en route les heures
supplémentaires c'est savoir qu'il faut
enfin sortir une bonne fois pour toutes
des 35 Hees et comprendre qu'il ne peut
pas y avoir de réforme juste des
retraites si ce n'est une réforme qui
met à égalité le public et le privé et
supprime tous les régimes spéciaux de
[Applaudissements]
retraite et oui
oui être
républicain c'est avoir le courage de
poser la question de
l'immigration bien sûr par le passé
notre pays a été construit par des
générations qui venaient de l'étranger
mais qui venaient en ayant le souci de
travailler et en transmettant à leurs
enfants un message devenez plus français
que les Français aujourd'hui cette
intégration c'est en grande partie
perdue parce que les gens et certains
qui viennent chez nous
VI plus pour trer mais pour bénéficier
d'un système social que nous offr sans
même demander qu'il co qu'il trava cela
ne peut plus continuer il est temps de
revenir au fondement de la République la
République c'est l'assimilation et ça
n'est pas le
communautarisme alors pour
finir mes amis ne nous faisons pas
d'illusion nous aurons beaucoup
d'obstacles nous aurons beaucoup
d'ennemis nous aurons beaucoup de
critiques mais je veux vous le dire
n'ayez pas de crainte n'ayez pas de
doute n'ayez pas peur ayez confiance je
vous le dis je sais où sont les vrais
républicains ils sont en face de nous et
nous ne laisserons plus à partir de ce
moment les socialistes nous dictter ce
que nous avons le droit de dire oui la
France n'a pas à renoncer à ce qu'elle
est elle doit redevenir ce qu'elle était
et n'est pas à la République de
s'adapter aux étrangers c'est aux
étrangers de s'adapter à la République
alors
qu'attendonsnous qu'attendonsnous pour
nous
leverattendonsnous pour redonner à la
France son espoir vous êtes les
républicains vous êtes la France
levez-vous pour défendre les valeurs de
la République
merci